la présence du front national au
deuxième tour de la présidentielle a mis
des milliers de personnes dans les rues
plus de 100000 les lycéens ont été les
premiers à se mobiliser dans une
vingtaine de villes ce soir dix mille
personnes ont défilé à lille 12 me
latour 10000 à strasbourg 6000 à dijon
laurence ragon lloyd le moigne à
sciences po paris comme ailleurs les
élèves partent manifesté une grève
générale a été lancé ces étudiants se
prépare à assumer des responsabilités
publiques
ils ont été surpris par les résultats du
premier tour la majorité d'entre eux
estiment que la démocratie est en danger
aujourd'hui on a banalisé l'extrême
droite c'est ça qui est grave force de
banaliser l'extrême droite
merci nalement l'extrême droite c'est un
peu parti comme les autres va nous en
dit long on est en démocratie on a des
adversaires la droite et la gauche dans
un seul ennemi c'est roanne les élèves
de sciences po ont rejoint la
manifestation spontanée organisée place
de la république à paris
ce sont les lycéens et les étudiants qui
ont lancé ce mouvement de protestation
un peu partout en france
descendus dans les rues de lyon ils ont
fait le tour des établissements
scolaires pour rallier à leur cause ont
des pages tout ce qui lui passait la
gauche la droite on en a plus rien à
[ __ ] aujourd'hui tous ces codes
raja le pad
simple lycéens membres de ras le front
du ps ou du pc dix mille personnes ont
manifesté à nancy bhl c'est l'une des
plus fortes mobilisations hier soir en
lorraine jean marie le pen est arrivé en
tête des suffrages avec 21,3 pour cent
des voix je suis d'une génération on a
lutté pour pour tous nos droits pour la
démocratie mais là c'est vraiment danger
vrai qu'il y ait plus de monde que ça
concert de sifflets à lille où un
cortège a rassemblé dix mille personnes
dans le nord fief historique de la
gauche le leader du fn a devancé lionel
jospin au total en france ce sont près
de cent mille personnes qui ont marché
contre le front national peut être un
avant goût des rassemblements du 1er mai